alors j'aimerais qu'on vienne sur une
affaire sur eux sur un une idée qui a
été dit et c'est zineb voilà voilà qui a
dit ça qu'est dit qu'il fallait tirer à
balles réelles dans les banlieues je me
suis insurgé contre elle sert une
cuisine est belle race exactement j'en
ai pris plein la gueule qui est rescapé
ces attentats de chambre elle paraît ce
qu'appelle par caméra cachée elle voit
là pardon je me permets cette incise
parce qu'il pousse à beaucoup d'elle
mais elle n'est pas rescapés de sciences
où elle n'était pas là bas le jour c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu bizarre de
leur jour utiliser cette ce vocabulaire
pour exactement parce que moi je vois là
alors vous avez vu moi j'ai pris là j'ai
pris le parti de dire qu'elle avait dit
n'importe quoi qu'elle avait dérapé
je me suis pris plein la gueule voilà
partout est ce que vous comprenez des
gens qui puissent dire on va tirer à
balles réelles dans les banlieues moi
alors je vous dis je le redis ce soir
quand j'entends quelqu'un dire ça
franchement elle peut être voilà vous
alors on dit ah les rescapés de charlie
hebdo entre guillemets voilà lé souhait
les sous protection policière
mais ça nous ça n'empêche pas qu'on ne
peut pas dire n'importe quoi non plus on
peut pas aller tirer à balles réelles
dans les banlieues je suis désolé voilà
quand moi je vois des jeunes comme
ibrahima voilà je ne peux pas penser
qu'on va aller tirer à balles réelles
contre des jeunes comme ça contre tous
les jeunes qui sont au public pour moi
on peut pas dire tout et n'importe quoi
parce qu'on est sous protection
policière je suis désolé voilà alors
c'est vrai qu'on est tombé dessus
voilà à cause de ça voilà dans tous les
sens mais je continue à le redire et je
redis je pense qu'elle avait fait un
très gros dérapage et que le gros
dérapage est de son côté plutôt que
d'une autre voilà je vous dis oui on est
un jeune en bouillie qui voudrait qu'il
voudrait parler juste ce qu'on peut
donner un micro sous plait merci
joseph fils et barella l'assistant
réalisera est allé manger et fait quoi
tu en train de ses bons et regards et il
regarde le film sur tf1 alors oui
comment tu t'appelles
il vend qu'est ce tu voulais raconter
tout ce que je viens de dire un profit
d'un micro monde à berne à micro-ondes
bien micro non mais tu peux parler bien
d'un micro ont fait un débat sur les
causes le pourquoi du comment moi bien
dans le micro parler à nos micros on
tire des conclusions hâtives mais on ne
se met pas la face des victimes ça fait
là on en train de demander ce2 essayer
de savoir pourquoi il ya eu telle
dégradation pour
et tel comment dire ça ait eu des
bavures policières on va agir mais sans
se mettre à la place des 153 151 151
interpellé sur les 151
est ce que je dis là et mayala cinq ou
six qui était il n'y a aucune preuve
formelle en disant oui
lui l'a fait si lui l'a fait ça y est
certains ressortent avec des séquelles à
vie me fait de rester une norme à 13
heures 3 heures dans des conditions
pitoyables
ils sont mus lits et des parents sont
chez eux et c'est ce que nous a dit
ibrahim a alors juste un parasite eve
prépare à signer sans vous poser est ce
que zineb el-rhazoui quand elle
intervient un peu à droite à gauche puis
vous savez où peut-être d'autres peaux
mates et when you me répondent ce cas
les pays à les payer
oui je pense que oui donc en fait assuré
qu'ils allaient payer donc en fait moi
je suis rappelé qu'elle ait payé quand
il appellera zaoui dit saoudite c'est un
dérapage c'est un propos qui est
clairement assumée et en fait il en
train de se passer exactement l inverse
de ce qu on veut dénoncer moi j'ai
décidé pour sa d'arrêter de m'indigner
sur twitter un moment je commence à
péter les plombs y avoir
systématiquement plein de polémiques
j'ai envie de partager on aime regarder
ce qu'il a dit zemmour a dit ça il n'a
pas dit ça mais en fait qu'est-ce qui se
passe ça fait du buzz savoir le dell qui
ont l'art et un fils est exactement donc
en fait j'ai envie d'arrêter de
s'indigner toutes les 30 secondes parce
que ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va laisser
passer
hélas ce qu'elle a fait c'est
contre-productif elle parlait à la base
du guet-apens fait aux policiers et moi
j'étais du côté des policiers qui ont
subi la foudre
donc le discours de reproduction les
politiciens sur et donc ces gens là qui
attisent la haine
ils en font leur commerce et moi et moi
je voudrais dire que je reviens là
dessus parce que voilà on avait dit que
j'avais des fonds du groupe à j'avais
des fonds du goût pas sur le fond pas
sur la forme voilà c'est qu'il avait dit
c'est vrai que c'était hallucinant ce
qu'elle avait dit et je vous dis c'est
hallucinant de dire ça 1 pour les
policiers c'est vraiment cessé c'est
franchement c'est très très mauvais pour
les policiers est très mauvais pour les
jeunes de banlieue quand vous entendez
ça david de bars quelqu'un qui dit il
faut aller tirer à balles réelles dans
les banlieues où vous dites moi même je
sais pas si c'est un actuellement et
personne ne réclame simple il faut
rappeler que la police n'a jamais tiré à
balles réelles dans les banlieues c'est
vrai
vivant dieu merci c'est faux mais non
madame c'est faux mais non à ses fans on
ne prenait pas un fait divers pour dire
que la police tire à balles réelles dans
les banlieues cette longue liste qui
gère tonnes moi je de l'histoire de ce
dérapage ans depuis le 17 octobre 1961
paraît non vais vous dire ce qu'ils ont
entendu que la police assassinat balle
réelle confiance à balles réelles mais
amine ben tounsi par exemple faire une
benne tout silvana en plus d'affaires
est pas en cours à l'azalaï tlf si vous
vous êtes dans le dos on va parler de
mantes-la-jolie youssef skype dans les
années 90 balles dans la nuque
ce sont des fermes et ultra essais en
iran mais en banlieue etc des balles
réelles et les voilà est souvent la
balle elle arrive ou dans la nuit
passion du débat si vous avez
l'honnêteté de reconnaître que ça n'est
pas aussi simpliste que vous le faites
avec ce qu'on voudra pas le ballon
toutes les lèvres el rhazoui l ami
danger tout le monde bien sûr elle met
en danger les jambes banlieue et met en
danger les flics dont s'est complètement
c'est maintenant l'un d'entre eux
productif c'est complètement scandaleux
comme parce que reynald quand vous être
en sus bien les mains de gens qui la
défendent et des bien pensants qui la
défendent qui se sont insurgés contre
moi sur twitter manche m'en fous un peu
me dévoile tout peut-être dire et je
continuerai et je vous le dit ce qu'elle
a dit c'est inadmissible et c'est pas
parce qu'on est sous protection
policière qu'on peut tout se permettre
elle dit vraiment là elle à l'appel
allen elle appelle à la guerre civile
c'est pour moi c'est oui c'est simple
depuis tout à l'heure on parle d'une
situation sociale absolument
inacceptable il ya un problème quand
même grave de concentration en gros
paquet de richesse ici et d'un gros
paquet pauvres là donc vous avez voilà
un système qui défendent on va dire on
va passer à l'oligarchie qui défend son
bout de gras et qui préfèrent problème
c'est la jeunesse et les gilets jaunes
que la façon de traiter ça ça va être la
répression policière parce que tant
qu'on parle de ça on ne parle pas un en
touche pas au grisbi
on touche pas des fois il faut il faut
comprendre être en campagne peut
expliquer beaucoup de choses mais alors
en être à raconter ça franchement ces
marchés qui défend les intérêts
financiers non mais
non mais c'est quand même gonflé pas par
contre c'est la police on n'est pas dans
la politique ça fait 30 ans que ça dure
on n'a rien fait d'autre part toutes les
choses comme il fallait les faire eric
naulleau je te trouve d'autant plus
gonflé que dans le bouquin du
commissaire il ya quand même des mises
en cause de certains propos de la france
insoumise mois qu'ils sont faux yahia
rim afin qu'ils sont faux ce sont des
lieux à delhi pour des poursuites en
plein discours anti police voilà mettre
de l'huile sur le feu et les met en
danger dont tu te trouve qu'on fait
quand tu nous fais d'autres numéros dont
numéro jo tout s'explique par l'or a + b
égal c'est ben non carrier le compliqué
car il voulait réagir chose taloche les
virages action sur la dame là que vous
avez évoqué la déco qui a tenu des
propos qui sont totalement scandaleux
scandaleux mais scandaleux et comment
nous ne ne pas le dire comment c'est un
appel au meurtre entre et c'est ça mais
la police doit tirer à balles réelles
c'est un appel au meurtre c'est une
parité ceux qui sont susceptibles de
défendre un appel au meurtre sonne déjà
comme un problème
oui on est on est plus dans la
république là on est dans l'autre chose
au niveau d'autres choses d'autres
choses qui semblent tolérer merger
plateau parler d'eux que ça disait on
s'est dit c'est fait des plateaux télé
tu as raison de dire pourquoi c'est le
finir laisser le finir car il n en est
pas ce que je veux dire c'est fait je
vais dire quelque chose il ya des gens
qui vont peut-être pas comprendre
à une époque il y avait ce qu'on appelle
des centre loisirs jeunesse les clj
c'était des fonctionnaires de police qui
menait des activités sportives de
préventive dans les quartiers il y avait
eu un contact qu'ils étaient très forts
entre certains policiers certains jeunes
et autres et puis il y en a d'autres qui
organisait des matchs de rugby jean
pierre avril à toulouse
et puis je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez de la sortie de nicolas sarkozy
qui était arrivé aux responsabilités
cavaliers la police et les parfums elle
n'est pas là pour jouer
guy comme si j'aime caravane ne faisais
que ça quand il mettait en place une
activité sportive sous le sceau du rugby
c'était évidemment pas pour que les
fonctions de police par chamakh ans
s'amuse
il y avait un objectif derrière mieux
connaître les jeunes que les jeunes
mieux que connaissent mais la police qui
est de la confiance qui se nouent qui
est des relations apaisées et qui est la
part de choses qui soit fait entre des
gars comme on vient de temps en temps
dans la ces gamins qu'ils aient envie
aujourd'hui de dire que ces gamins ils
sont pas respectueux de la règle et
permet tolérer que ces gamins fasse
office de contrôle au faciès répéter
c'est une honte
mais à côté de ça si les fonctions de
police connaît ces gamins il faut rend
la part des choses entre eux et ceux qui
sèment le trouble
ce qui à mon sens n'est pas ce problème
là c'est parce qu'il y en a on peut pas
expliquer que tout va bien non plus
c'est pas possible sinon ce serait nier
le réel hikari l'oréal c'est que le real
si tu peux rien leur et les cheveux
blancs vnc que les flics en brie mince
majorité des gamins des cités sans qu'on
veut c'est s'assurer qu'il n'a donné la
parole c'est bien sûr et je veux dire
regarde souvent d'ailleurs ce soir aux
bisous que le ministre de l'intérieur
mais ce castaner est prise en tenaille
public qui a découvert ce qui se passait
mal yeux ferait peut-être mieux de
remettre en place la police de proximité
une police qui connaît son territoire
agathe qui connaissent et habitant
remettre en place des activités de
confiance pour la restaurer entre les
jeunes et la police mais ça ça veut dire
quoi
ça veut dire que la question budgétaire
ça doit pas être un tabou on ne peut pas
dire simplement en fonction de police
vous aurez toujours moins d'effectifs
vous aurez toujours mon équipement vous
aurez toujours moins c'est pas possible
pas un moment donné il ya une société
française qui se craquèle qui se
fragmente est ce qu on me l'a reçu des
est-ce qu'on veut lui redonner de la
cohésion
il faut que la confiance entre eux et
ceux qui sont susceptibles de restaurer
l'ordre républicain
ça nécessite qu à un moment donné en
prennent tous conscience qu'on ne doit
plus se regarder dans la défiance
monsieur le bars avec madame doivent
agir ensemble
moi je le dis tranquillement soirée en
ce sens vous devez agir